Die Gesellschaft für Freiheitsrechte findet ihr im Internet unter freiheitsrechte.org. Und da kann man auch eine Auswahl der ganzen Fälle sehen, die von der GFF momentan behandelt werden. Und da geht es natürlich auch um die Strategie, also im Grunde das, worüber wir jetzt hier gerade gesprochen haben, lässt sich da nachlesen. Spenden kann man übrigens auch. Ich tippe mal, dass sozusagen die großen Spender jetzt nicht auf den Spende-Button auf dem Internet klicken, sondern dass ihr die über andere Kanäle anspricht. Aber wie man sich beteiligen kann, darüber sprechen wir später noch. Mit dem Spenden-Button geht das auf jeden Fall auch unter freiheitsrechte.org. Wenn ich das richtig in Erinnerung habe, verabschiedet sich Nora Marquardt an dieser Stelle? Genau. Und wir reden gleich noch weiter mit Ulf Burmeier, möglicherweise über das Anti-Whistleblower-Gesetz, das hier schon angesprochen wurde, zu dem mir ein Satz von Daniel Ellsberg eingefallen ist. Der Mann hinter den Pentagon-Papers jetzt also verfilmt in die Verlegerin, der nämlich sagte, you can't have a democracy without unauthorized disclosures. Also man kann keine Demokratie haben, ohne unerlaubtes Weiterzählen von gewissen Dingen. Tschüss Nora, vielen Dank. Ciao. Chaosradio Nr. 246, wir haben es kurz nach 11. Wir reden über Freiheitsrechte in diesen zwei Stunden in dieser Ausgabe. Zu Gast schon die gesamte Zeit ist Ulf Buermeyer. Ihr kennt ihn von der Lage der Nationen im Podcast. Er ist aber Gründer und Vorsitzender der Gesellschaft für Freiheitsrechte ebenfalls. Außerdem Richter am Landgericht Berlin und Sachverständiger im Innenausschuss des Bundestags zur Neustrukturierung des Bundeskriminalamtsgesetz. Insofern also auch schwer vertraut mit Dingen, die da möglicherweise jetzt noch auf uns zukommen in Berlin. Eben haben wir noch gehört, Nora Markert, Professorin in Hamburg für Öffentliches Recht, auch sie bei der GFF. Und die GFF beschäftigt uns natürlich noch weiter und einige ihrer Fälle. Etwas Spektakuläres, wo sozusagen das Verständnis, was Freiheit eigentlich bedeutet, vor allen Dingen Freiheit im Datenschutz bedeutet, ist immer genau diese Geschichte, die wir gerade schon angesprochen haben, mit Whistleblowern. Wir haben vor kurzem jetzt einen Film in den Kinos gehabt, die Verlegerin, da geht es um die Pentagon Papers, in denen erstmals sozusagen dargestellt wurde, wie schlimm die Amerikaner in den 60er Jahren in Vietnam dastanden, wie schlecht die Situation sozusagen aus Sicht der Amerikaner im Krieg war und wie lange das vereimlicht wurde, dass sozusagen Menschen offensichtlich als Soldaten in diesen Krieg geschickt wurde, der von der eigenen Regierung schon nicht mehr als gewinnbar eingeschätzt war. Und das ist ein Leak gewesen von Daniel Ellsberg. Und darum geht es in diesem Film. Und er hat eben auch gesagt, diesen Satz, den ich beeindruckend finde, in einem Vice-Interview war das, You can't have a democracy without unauthorized disclosures. Also man kann keine Demokratie haben, ohne nicht ab und zu mal auch ein kleines Geheimnis zu verraten. Uff, das ist ja dann auch nicht mehr recht an der Stelle, wenn jemand ein Geheimnis tatsächlich verrät oder doch?
Ja, das ist schon richtig, was du sagst. In den meisten Fällen ist es so, dass die Whistleblower schon gegen irgendein Gesetz verstoßen. Wenn sie Beamte sind, ist es häufig ein Verrat von Dienstgeheimnissen. Oder wenn es Mitarbeiter in einer Firma sind, kann es auch der Verrat von Geschäftsgeheimnissen sein. Also da gibt es schon viele Gesetze, gegen die man verstoßen kann als Whistleblower. Deswegen wäre es so wichtig, dass man einen Rechtsrahmen schafft, der unter bestimmten Bedingungen Whistleblowing legal macht. Das wäre natürlich der Idealfall, wenn man sich also gar nicht mehr strafbar machen würde. Wenigstens aber, solange wir so weit nicht gekommen sind, muss es möglich sein, dass Whistleblowing an die Presse straffrei bleibt. Und wenn wir da keine Straffreiheit direkt schaffen können, dann ist die zweitbeste Lösung, dass die Whistleblower jedenfalls darauf vertrauen können, dass man sie nicht erwischen wird. Und das ist einer der vielen, vielen Gründe, warum Internet-Massenüberwachung oder warum zum Beispiel auch die Vorratsdatenspeicherung so gefährlich ist, weil man damit eben unter anderem auch die Kommunikationsbeziehung von Journalistinnen und Journalisten aufdecken kann.
Jetzt ist natürlich die Frage, also was wiegt da mehr? Das Geheimnis, weil es beispielsweise um Staatssicherheit geht oder gerade bei den Pentagon Papers um die Lage der Nationen natürlich auch. Oder das Interesse der Öffentlichkeit an den Dingen, die da ans Licht gebracht werden. Wer darf das denn eigentlich abwägen? Also wenn jemand mit solchen entsprechenden Geheimnissen zu euch kommen würde, dürftet ihr den hören oder dürftet ihr mit diesen Informationen irgendetwas anstellen?
Also ich würde ehrlich gesagt zunächst mal sagen, zur GFF sollte man mit solchen Staatsgeheimnissen nicht kommen, sondern das ist genau der Punkt, deswegen habe ich das eben auch gleich ins Spiel gebracht. Ich finde, solche Leaks sollten immer an Journalistinnen und Journalisten gehen. Und zwar einfach deswegen, weil die dafür ausgebildet sind, einzuschätzen, ob diese Informationen tatsächlich echt sind zunächst mal. Das ist ja eine ganz wichtige Frage. Es kann ja auch sein, dass es einfach Fake News sind. Das ist das eine. Und zum anderen, weil die natürlich auch dazu ausgebildet sind, abzuwägen, welches Interesse denn jetzt im konkreten Einsfall überwiegt. Ob sie diese Informationen verwerten, ob sie sie direkt veröffentlichen, ob sie quasi die PDF-Datei ins Netz stellen oder ob sie nur bestimmte Informationen daraus verwenden, um dann weiter zu recherchieren zum Beispiel. Und deswegen denke ich, man muss durchaus jetzt keine Radikal-Lösung dergestalt schaffen, dass man sagt, man schafft einfach alle Dienstgeheimnisse ab. Es gibt ja auch Dienstgeheimnisse, die durchaus einen bestimmten Sinn machen. Du hast gerade schon zum Beispiel so Fälle der nationalen Sicherheit oder der Verteidigung angeführt. Es ist ja völlig klar, dass man jetzt irgendwie die Geheimnisse der Bundeswehr in bestimmten Situationen schützen muss. Aber man muss sie aus meiner Sicht eben nicht schützen vor Leaks an die Presse, denn da vertraue ich darauf, dass Journalistinnen und Journalisten dann verantwortungsbewusst damit umgehen und keine Hierarchiereaktionen starten. Ich finde wichtig bei dieser Abwägung den Gedanken, den du eben schon zitiert hast von Daniel Ellsberg, dass es eben keine Demokratie gibt ohne Leaks. Und dann möchte ich noch ein bisschen präzisieren. Es muss ja durchaus nicht so sein, dass alle Informationen irgendwann geleakt werden. Ich finde das Wesentliche ist, dass alle Menschen, die mit Geheimnissen arbeiten, wissen, es könnte sein, dass sie geleakt werden. Und das ist aus meiner Sicht eine zentrale Bedingung dafür, dass die Menschen sich in Behörden auch noch ans Recht halten. Wenn ich in einer Behörde arbeite und quasi willkürlich Informationen als geheim deklarieren kann und wenn ich dann darauf vertrauen kann, dass es wirklich niemand mehr prüfen kann, dass es niemals seinen Weg in die Presse findet, dann bin ich ja nicht mehr gehindert alle möglichen, sagen wir mal, jedenfalls rechtlich fragwürdigen Dinge zu tun, weil ja einfach niemand mehr drauf guckt. Wenn ich aber damit rechnen muss, dass vielleicht jedenfalls jedes tausendste Geheimnis tatsächlich irgendwann in der BILD-Zeitung steht, dann werde ich möglicherweise mir zweimal überlegen, ob ich bei meiner Arbeit unter dem Schutz von Geheimnissen das Recht breche. Also deswegen würde ich ganz im Gegenteil sagen, der Rechtsstaat verlangt, dass es jedenfalls ein Risiko eines liegt. Es muss nicht alles geleakt werden, aber jeder, der mit geheimen Unterlagen arbeitet, der muss im Geiste davon ausgehen, es könnte ein Lieg geben, um tatsächlich sich selbst noch ans Recht zu halten.
Das heißt, der umgekehrte Satz von Erzberg stimmt ja eigentlich dann auch. Es kann keine Demokratie ohne Geheimnisse geben. Kann man den auch so stehen lassen?
Das weiß ich nicht. Ich denke, dass es schon einfach viele Bereiche gibt, in denen die Verwaltung mit Daten arbeitet, die nicht so ohne weiteres an die Öffentlichkeit kommen sollten. Zum Beispiel, weil es die Öffentlichkeit einfach verunsichern könnte und dann zu Panikreaktionen führen könnte. Insofern glaube ich, muss man schon in manchen Situationen sich sehr genau überlegen, was man veröffentlicht. Ich bin also insofern kein radikaler Gegner, jedes Verwaltungsgeheimnisses. Ich sehe da schon, dass es bestimmte Grenzen geben muss. Ich denke nur, dass wir in einer Kultur leben, wo die Verwaltung es mit den Geheimnissen traditionell sehr übertreibt. Aber da leben wir gerade in einer Zeit, wo ein langsamer, ganz gemächlicher Kulturwandel einsetzt. Stichwort Informationsfreiheitsgesetze, also immer mehr Bürgerinnen und Bürger stellen Fragen an die Verwaltung, möchten einfach wissen, mit was die Verwaltung so arbeitet. Und wir erleben da auch als GFF ja mehr ein Programm, das wir Transparenzklagen nennen, wo wir also Menschen unterstützen, deren IFG-Anträge abgelehnt worden sind, wo Behörden also Unterlagen nicht rausrücken wollten. Als GFF erleben wir also schon noch erhebliche Widerstände in den Behörden, das muss man deutlich sagen. Also nicht alle Beamtinnen und Beamten finden das so richtig gut, sich in die Karten schauen zu lassen. Viele haben noch so diesen alten preußischen Gedanken im Kopf, das sind meine Akten. Und ich vertraue aber darauf, dass sich da einfach ein Kulturwandel einstellen wird, dahin zu sagen, das sind nicht die Akten der Behörde, sondern das sind die Akten der Menschen in Deutschland, denn die haben schließlich die Behörde bezahlt mit ihren Steuern.
Lassen wir uns noch mal kurz bei den Wisseblowern bleiben. Was haben wir denn für eine rechtliche Lage momentan? Also wenn ich jetzt im Besitz von sensiblen Informationen bin, die irgendwelche Betrügereien oder dunkle Machenschaften von Seiten des Gesetzgebers beinhalten, jetzt sagst du, okay, geh zum Journalisten, die können das durchchecken, aber was ist denn dann der rechtliche Rahmen am Ende? Also bin ich in irgendeiner Form geschützt, wenn da öffentliches Interesse besteht? Wie sieht es aus?
Also Journalistinnen und Journalisten haben grundsätzlich ein Zeugnis Verweigerungsrecht. Das heißt also, sie müssen zunächst mal keine Auskunft geben über den Namen und die oder sonst die Identität ihrer Informantinnen und Informanten. Da gibt es einen grundsätzlichen Schutz. Der hat zwar hier und da auch Lücken, das muss man ehrlich sagen, aber jedenfalls grundsätzlich mal gibt es einen Schutz, der ist nicht 150% perfekt, weil in manchen Situationen quasi auch eine Abwägung stattfinden muss. Da ist es also kein absoluter Schutz, sondern da wird abgewogen zwischen dem quasi dem Quellenschutz und anderen Interessen. Aber im Großen und Ganzen...
Wer übernimmt denn solche Abwägungen eigentlich?
Ja, es gibt zum Beispiel so Abwägungsklauseln im BKA-Gesetz. Es gibt ja auch nach dem BKA-Gesetz eine ganze Reihe heimlicher Überwachungsmaßnahmen und normalerweise dürfen Daten von Journalistinnen und Journalisten nicht verwandt werden, die dabei so quasi im Filter hängen bleiben, aber es gibt eben Ausnahmefälle, wo das doch geht. Insofern, das geht jetzt sehr ins Detail, deswegen will ich das nicht zu lange ausführen. Ich wollte nur sagen, die Grundregel ist aber schon, dass es sowas gibt wie einen Quellenschutz, also grundsätzlich müssen Menschen, die bei der Presse arbeiten, ihre Quellen nicht offenlegen. Es gibt ein paar Lücken, aber im Grundsatz zählt es schon und man muss sich einfach nur überlegen, mit welchen Kommunikationsmitteln wende ich mich an die Presse und man muss leider sagen, in den Zeiten, wo eben extrem viel elektronische Kommunikation gespeichert wird, jedenfalls quasi die Umstände der Kommunikation, die sogenannten Metadaten, also wer hat mit wem kommuniziert, da ist immer noch das sicherste, einfach einen Brief zu schicken. So traurig das ist. Wenn man heikle Informationen hat, die per E-Mail zu schicken, ist nicht so ganz ungefährlich. Das kann man auch machen, wenn man sehr genau weiß, was man tut. Manche Medien haben ja sogenannte Secure Drop Systeme, da geht das relativ gut, aber wenn man jetzt sagt, ich bin jetzt eher nicht so der Techie, dann sollte man heikle Informationen schlicht per Brief an die Redaktion schicken. Dann hat man die allerbesten Karten, dass man keine Spuren hinterlässt.
Ich darf aber auch eine CD brennen, das geht dann schon.
Wir sind eben wirklich durch eine Vielzahl von Überwachungsgesetzen und durch unglaublich viele Datenspeicherungen in allen Ecken und Enden in einer Situation, wo es sehr gefährlich ist, mit digitalen Mitteln Informationen an die Presse zu übermitteln. Es sei denn, man weiß sehr genau, was man tut. Es gibt Möglichkeiten, dem zu entgehen. Also eine naheliegende ist zum Beispiel, wenn man die Handynummer hat einer Journalistin, Signal ist relativ sicher als Messenger, weil die eben keine Metadaten speichern. Die könnten das theoretisch, sie schwören aber, dass sie das nicht tun. Und Menschen, denen ich vertraue, sagen, man kann denen vertrauen. Also Signal ist, denke ich, zurzeit vielleicht der beste Kompromiss zwischen User-Freundlichkeit und Sicherheit, um Daten an die Presse zu bringen. Aber dann muss man halt die Handynummer kennen, des Menschen, den man da anfunkten will.
Und der muss dann auch Signal haben. Jetzt sagt er, Danimo ist natürlich auch zu Gast hier. Hab ich gar nicht mehr vorgestellt. Aber jetzt muss er reinspringen.
Ja, das mit dem Papier wollte ich noch mal gerade ein bisschen.
Das schmeckt dem Chaos Computer Club gar nicht mehr.
Ja, wir erinnern uns, es gab letztens einen Fall, wo jemand genau daran, dass er das über einen Kopierer gejagt hat, die Dokumente. Und das gibt es auch bei Druckern, die hinterlassen mittlerweile auch eindeutige Signaturen auf dem Papier, die nicht wirklich sichtbar sind, es sei denn, man weiß genau, wo man hingucken muss. Darüber lässt sich dann gegebenenfalls auch die Geräte nochmal identifizieren. Darüber lässt sich dann meistens gerade, wenn man das auf einem Firmenrechner macht, identifizieren, wer das gedruckt hat, oder auf einem Behördendrucker. Ist also auch nicht so einfach. Also tatsächlich vielleicht erst mal Tufühlung mit einem Journalisten aufnehmen.
Und dann sollen die sagen, wie die Informationen übermittelt werden.
Genau.
Bevor man einfach was schickt. Gibt es denn spektakuläre Blowerfälle, von denen ich jetzt in Deutschland nichts weiß? Ich denke immer nur an Edward Snowden und dann natürlich geht der Gedanke an die Pentagon-Papers oder Panama-Papers, hier Paradise-Papers. Da waren ja mehrere P-Papers, die die letzten beiden hatten, mit Steueroasen zu tun. Gibt es Fälle, wo man sagen könnte, dass es ja da hat man doch gesehen, wie das funktioniert?
Also rund um den NSA-Untersuchungsausschuss zum Beispiel gab es ja eine ganze Reihe von auch prominenten Leaks, wo einfach Informationen durchgestochen wurden. Teilweise wurde dann ja auch quasi von Seiten der Behörden sehr deutlich das kritisiert und so getan, als wenn quasi der Bundestag systematisch undicht sei. Und das wurde dann wiederum als Argument verwendet, dass man dem Bundestag möglichst wenig Informationen geben soll. Und interessanterweise haben dann Journalistinnen und Journalisten gesagt, naja, also nicht alles kam aus dem Parlament. Es kam auch einiges aus den Behörden, die dann ganz gezielt wiederum Propaganda gemacht haben. Also rund um den NSA-Untersuchungsausschuss gab es eine ganze Menge an Whistleblowing. Aber es gibt zum Beispiel auch im privaten Bereich immer wieder solche Fälle. Wir haben ja als GFF vor kurzem oder vor anderthalb Jahren etwa eine Verfassungsbeschwerde erhoben gegen ein Strafgesetz, auf das wir vielleicht gleich noch kommen. Und da spielt ein Whistleblowing-Fall aus der Privatwirtschaft eine große Rolle, der so schön anschaulich ist. Deswegen würde ich den vielleicht mal kurz erzählen. Und zwar geht es da um die Dating-Plattform LeVou. Das ist so ein bisschen so das deutsche Tinder oder OkCupid, kannte ich auch nicht. Aber da ist es irgendwie wohl so, dass wie auf jeder Dating-Plattform es irgendwie viel mehr Männer als Frauen gibt, die die Plattform nutzen. Und das ist natürlich nicht so richtig klasse für das Geschäftsmodell, weil das für die Männer natürlich unattraktiv ist, wenn sie keine Frauen finden können. Und vor allem ist das für das Geschäftsmodell deswegen doof, weil Männer dafür bezahlen müssen auf dieser Plattform, wenn sie Frauen Nachrichten schreiben. Und wenn da wenig Frauen auf der Plattform sind, dann schreiben die Männer wenig Nachrichten und LeVou verdient wenig Geld. Deswegen haben die sich einen Trick überlegt vor einigen Jahren. Die haben einfach Frauen gefaked. Sie haben also quasi Skripten geschrieben, die dann so getan haben, als wären sie eine Frau und haben auf diese Art und Weise dazu Männer verleitet, immer mehr Nachrichten zu schreiben an diese Fakefrauen. Und das ist ein ziemlich eindeutiger Fall des Betruges oder Computerbetruges, je nachdem wie die Details jeweils sind. Und das ist durchgestochen worden an die CT, also das Computermagazin aus dem Heiseverlag. Die haben also Daten durchgestochen bekommen, ich glaube vier Gigabyte oder so, im Prinzip E-Mail-Inboxen, so Outlook-Messageboxen. Und da war quasi so der E-Mail-Verkehr der Chefetage von LeVou drin, wo man auch ganz genau sehen konnte, die wussten, was sie tun. Und das ist halt ein klassischer Fall von Whistleblowing. Der hatte einfach einen Mitarbeiter, wahrscheinlich von LeVou, der ein schlechtes Gewissen bekommen hat, hat diese Daten durchgestochen an die Presse, um das Ganze dann mal an die Öffentlichkeit zu bringen. Und das hat Heise dann natürlich auch publiziert und auch an die Staatsanwaltschaft. Der Verlag der CT rausbringt. Ja genau, der Verlag der CT rausbringt, hat das dann auch an die Staatsanwaltschaft gegeben und hat das aber auch groß berichtet. Und da sind dann tatsächlich auch Leute festgenommen worden. Also das ist schon ein Fall, der wirklich tatsächlich Folgen hatte. Und ich meine, immerhin sind da ja auch Tausende von Männern betrogen worden. Also um ihr Geld, aber auch um ihr Vertrauen. Und deswegen finde ich das ein schönes Beispiel, warum es so wichtig ist, dass man Daten durchstechen kann.
Jetzt kann man doch aber an der Stelle sehen, hat doch alles super geklappt. Dann ist die Rechtspflege doch fantastisch für Whistleblower in Deutschland.
Ganz genau. Sie war fantastisch, bis die Datenhele reichen. Na ja, sie waren natürlich nicht fantastisch. Es gibt immer noch Lücken im Whistleblower-Schutz. Wie gesagt, es ist nach wie vor noch strafbar, wenn man solche Sachen durchsticht. Das heißt, man muss immer darauf vertrauen, dass es nicht rauskommt. Das ist natürlich nicht optimal. Auch arbeitsrechtlich ist man da also überhaupt nicht abgesichert. Da könnte man immer noch gekündigt werden dafür. Insofern, die Rechtslage ist wahrlich nicht perfekt, aber sie ist 2015 auch nicht etwa verbessert, sondern noch mal deutlich verschlechtert worden, als nämlich die damalige große Koalition ein neues Strafgesetz beschlossen hat. Den Straftat bestand der Datenhelerei. Und das ist dieses Gesetz, das du schon kurz angesprochen hast. Das stellt im Prinzip unter Strafe, wenn man sich gestohlene Daten verschafft oder gestohlene Daten weitergibt, gestohlen jetzt mal untechnisch formuliert, also Daten, die irgendwie durch eine Straftat abhanden gekommen sind, wenn man die dann quasi weitergibt oder sich verschafft.
Und worum ging es da ursprünglich? Was hatten die Gesetzgeber im Visier bei diesem Paragrafen?
Ursprünglich hatten die im Visier zum Beispiel die Situation, dass Kreditkartendaten geklaut werden bei einer Zahlungsverkehrsfirma und die dann im Internet gehandelt werden. Das ist natürlich ein offensichtlicher Fall, was nicht sein sollte. Natürlich sollte man im Internet nicht irgendwie 1000 Kreditkartennummern kaufen können, um dann damit irgendwelche Betrügereien zu starten.
Und da wollte man nicht nur die Leute bestrafen können, die die Kreditkartendaten mal geklaut haben, sondern auch die, die damit dann Handel treiben.
Ganz genau, und auch noch nicht mal... Also Datenhilerei klingt so nach Handel treiben, aber schlafer macht man sich schon, wenn man die auch unentgeltlich sich einfach nur irgendwie verschafft. Das heißt also, diese Grundidee des Gesetzes war okay, das Gesetz ist aber viel zu weit formuliert. Deswegen erfasst es nicht etwa nur gestohlene Kreditkartendaten oder gestohlene Logins, was vielleicht okay wäre, sondern es erfasst einfach sämtliche Daten und darunter fallen eben auch Daten von Whistleblowern. Das ist das große Problem, weil Daten von Whistleblowern, wenn die weitergegeben werden an jemanden, dann eben auch quasi gestohlene Daten, abhandengekommene Daten sind. Wenn ich jetzt als Journalist mir diese einmal schon weitergegebenen Daten verschaffe oder sie als Journalist weitergebe an einen dritten, zum Beispiel einen CCC-Mitglied, ein Nerd, der diese Daten analysiert, dann können sich sowohl der Journalist als auch der CCC-Hacker, der also diese Daten analysieren will, strafbar machen nach der Datenhehlerei. Und das ist, wie man sich vorstellen kann, ausgesprochen gefährlich für investigativen Journalismus, weil natürlich in diesem Bereich ganz häufig mit gestohlenen Daten, mit abhandengekommenen Daten, eben mit Daten von Whistleblowern gearbeitet werden muss. Es gab ursprünglich in dem Gesetz gar keine Schutzvorschrift für Journalisten. Dann habe ich da einen Blogbeitrag geschrieben bei Netzpolitik. Daraufhin haben die das Gesetz dann auch noch ein bisschen nachgebessert, diesen Entwurf. Aber diese Schutzklausel für Journalisten ist immer noch viel zu eng. Das heißt, es gibt immer noch viele Fälle aus der Praxis, die strafbar wären. Und deswegen haben wir uns da mit Reporter ohne Grenzen zusammengetan und mit vielen anderen Menschen aus der Presse. Markus Becke dal ist zum Beispiel dabei. Oder eben auch einige Journalisten vom Heiseverlag, zum Beispiel die Leute, die damals mit den LeVu-Daten gearbeitet haben. Und die haben gesagt, das, was wir damals gemacht haben, könnten wir heute so nicht mehr tun, einfach weil es die Datenhehlerei unter Strafe stellt. Und das halten wir für gefährlich. Und das Bundesverfassungsgericht hat diese Verfassungsbeschwerde inzwischen auch zugestellt. Das bedeutet, die Bundesregierung wurde aufgefordert, darauf zu antworten, auf unsere Kritik. Und das ist jetzt noch keine Vorentscheidung, aber es ist ein gutes Zeichen. Denn die allermeisten Verfassungsbeschwerden, mehr als 99 Prozent, werden gar nicht erst zugestellt, sondern werden gleich irgendwie abgelehnt. Das heißt, die Zustellung ist jedenfalls ein Zeichen, dass wir in der ganz kleinen Gruppe von Verfassungsbeschwerden sind, die Aussicht auf Erfolg haben. Aber wir haben noch nicht gewonnen. Das muss man sagen. Es bleibt abzuwarten, was passiert.
Aber das ist einer der anhängigen Fälle, die ihr mit der GFF weiter begleitet. Ich kann mir das immer so schwer vorstellen. Vielleicht ein idealisiertes Bild von den Parlamentariern, von den Menschen, die für Gesetzgebung mitverantwortlich sind. Dass die dann so eine Kritik nicht ernst nehmen. Du hast in einem Blogartikel verfasst, die sich entzündete, noch mal ein bisschen an dem Gesetz gearbeitet. Sieht man das auf der Seite des Gesetzgebers nicht, dass es da noch Probleme gibt? Oder sagt man da, na gut, jetzt ist das Ding raus, da muss der Rechtsweg beschritten werden. Die sind auch Fans von der Veränderung. Oder schlägt euch da auch Abneigung entgegen, wenn man jetzt mit dem Verfassungsgericht kommt?
Also, nee, da ist uns noch keine Abneigung entgegengeschlagen, seit wir da gegen eben nach Karlsruhe gegangen sind. Ich könnte mir schon vorstellen, dass man im Justizministerium das jetzt nicht lustig fand, als der Brief aus Karlsruhe kam, dass es zugestellt ist, also, dass sie sich dazu bitte mal äußern sollen, weil natürlich auch die Menschen dort im Ministerium wissen, dass es ein ganz schlechtes Zeichen aus Sicht des Haares war, weil es eben so aussieht, als wenn die Verfassungsbeschwerde Erfolg haben könnte, könnte, es noch nicht entschieden könnte. Aber im Vorfeld war das schon mal ganz interessant, wir haben ja nicht erst Kritik geübt, als das Gesetz durch war, ich hab persönlich geblockt und es gab aber auch Kritik von ganz vielen anderen, also von Journalistenverbänden zum Beispiel. Und wir haben dann immer über eine Anfrage nach dem Informationsfreiheitsgesetz uns mal die Akten schicken lassen zum Datenhehlerei-Paragrafen aus dem Justizministerium, um mal zu schauen, wie das Gesetz eigentlich zustande gekommen ist und wieso diese total berechtigte Kritik nicht so richtig ernst genommen wurde. Und da kann man sehen, also diese erste Kritik, der Blockbeitrag bei Netzpolitik, der ist sofort Heiko Maas, dem damaligen Minister vorgelegt worden, und der hat dann irgendwie an den Rand geschrieben, hier nachbessern. Also das ist schon passiert. Man sieht dann ja quasi die Akten aus dem Ministerium, ob die vollständig sind, wage ich nicht einzuschätzen, aber das sah man irgendwie, dieser Netzpolitik-Blockbeitrag wurde halt ausgedruckt natürlich und dann dem Minister vorgelegt und der hat dann halt gesagt, hier nachbessern, also legt mich jetzt nicht fest auf den Wortlaut, aber sinngemäß steht am Rand, bitte was tun irgendwie. Und das Problem ist bloß, dass das Gesetz dann wieder bei demselben Referenten auf dem Tisch gelandet ist, also einem bayerischen Staatsanwalt, der Abgeordnet war damals ins Ministerium und der hat dann, wie man das sieht, also richtig in den Akten hatte überhaupt keine Lust, der fand sein Gesetz schon vorher ganz großartig und den hat dann total unwillig so ein ganz kleines bisschen nachgebessert, aber hat eben das Problem überhaupt nicht ernst genommen, weil er eine Kritik an seinem Gesetzentwurf und hat deswegen eine minimale Änderung vorgenommen, die eben jetzt nicht weit genug reicht. Und das reicht. Und das ist quasi das, was wir in unserer Verfassungsbeschwerde darlegen, welche konkreten Fälle aus der journalistischen Praxis diese Schutzklausel nicht abdeckt. Und da sieht man eben sehr schön an den Akten, dass der Referent aber keinen Bock darauf hatte, das zu ändern. Der wollte einfach möglichst wenig ändern an seinem Entwurf. Und im zweiten Durchgang hat das dann auch niemand mehr so richtig geprüft. Das ist das eigentlich, Herr Schütte. Also dann kommen da diese ganzen Pressemitteilungen rein und die ganzen Mahnenbriefe von Bundestagsabgeordneten auch, die sagen, hey, mir sprechen hier die Leute von meiner Lokalzeitung ein und sagen, das ist gefährlich, was ihr da macht. Und dann wird das alles dem Referenten vorgelegt. Der Referent sagt Quatsch. Und dann geht das so raus mit so einem Standard Textbaustein. Nein, das Gesetz ist super. Also jetzt hat sich alles sehr verkürzt und ein bisschen auf den Punkt gebracht. Aber genau so ist es gelaufen. Und das finde ich persönlich schon erschreckend, dass da letztlich dann mehr oder weniger ein Mensch, der da diesen Gesetzentwurf verantwortet hat, da was durchboxen kann. Und da offensichtlich selbst in einem so großen und so kompetenten Haus wie dem Justizministerium niemand mehr drüberguckt und das mal nochmal durchdenkt.
Ist das Arbeitsvolumen, ist das böser Wille, wollte man das jetzt so durchboxen, weil man eigentlich eine andere Agenda hat oder ist das wirklich einfach, ey, das muss jetzt fertig werden und deswegen hauen wir das jetzt hoch aus?
Also ich finde es immer ganz schwierig, so eine böse Agenda zu unterstellen. Ich glaube, der eigentliche Grund ist, dass man dieses Gesetz unbedingt huckepack mit der Vorratsdatenspeicherung durch den Bundestag schmuggeln wollte, damit darüber nicht zu viel diskutiert wird. Und dieses huckepack setzt da halt voraus, dass der Gesetzentwurf, dieser Teil Datenhehlerei, quasi auch schon fertig ist, wenn der Rest fertig ist. Man konnte quasi nicht auf die Datenhehlerei warten. Und die Vorratsdatenspeicherung ist ein Prestigeprojekt gewesen der alten Großen Koalition. Das musste also schnell durch den Bundestag. Ich glaube, man hat deswegen einfach die Einwände nicht so wirklich ernsthaft geprüft, weil man das Gesetz zur Vorratsdatenspeicherung nicht aufhalten wollte. Ich schätze, dass das der politische Grund ist. Das kann ich aber nicht nachweisen. Also das lässt sich in den Akten nicht dokumentieren. Man sieht nur, da ist eine Vermutung, muss ich so deutlich so kennzeichnen. Aber das liegt nahe vom Zeitablauf her, dass man halt einfach nicht warten wollte, bis man die Datenhelerei quasi wirklich sauber formuliert hat, damit das Gesamtprojekt Vorratsdatenspeicherung nicht irgendwie gebremst wird.
Also wenn es stimmt, dann kann man subsumieren, dass es manchmal ganz banal ist, warum Gesetze auf den Weg gebracht werden, die einfach nicht gut sind. Und die wahrscheinlich der Gesetzgeber auch so gar nicht wollte. Oder? Kann man das da sagen an der Stelle? Dass es nicht im Interesse des Gesetzgebers ist, Whistleblower sozusagen, als Auffallprodukt über diesen...
Ich hoffe das einfach mal. Ich wage da letztlich keine Interpretation, wie das zum Beispiel Heiko Maas sieht. Also er hat sich im Bundestag hingestellt bei der Verabschiedung des Gesetzes und hat ziemlich geschimpft über die Kritik von Seiten der Presse. Oder auch zum Beispiel meine Kritik, weil er sagt, es ist völliger Unsinn, die Presse ist gut geschützt und so. Aber es ist schwer einzuschätzen, ob er das geglaubt hat, was er da gesagt hat. Er hat also ziemlich auf die Brust geklopft. Aber ob er das wirklich glaubt, das weiß ich nicht.
Wir reden über Freiheitsrechte. Jetzt gerade über das Anti-Whistleblower-Gesetz. So wird es zumindest umschrieben in einschlägigen Blogs. Die Rede ist von Datenhehlereiparagrafen. Wir haben gleich noch eine halbe Stunde Chaosradio mit Ulf Burmeier von der Gesellschaft für Freiheitsrechte. Da werden wir über das Polizeiaufgabengesetz sprechen. Und dann hat uns noch eine Frage über das Telefoning erreicht. Da geht es ums Informationsfreiheitsgesetz. Und da geht es um einen internationalen Vergleich davon. Denn wir haben das Informationsfreiheitsgesetz noch nicht so lange. Es gibt viele andere Länder, die etwas Ähnliches haben. Die USA beispielsweise, Freedom of Information Act. Und die Schweden haben offensichtlich auch ein Informationsfreiheitsgesetz. Und danach wird gefragt. Mal gespannt, ob Ulf darauf antworten kann. Wir hören uns gleich wieder nach den Nachrichten und den Nerd-News. Vorher noch Kaltestadt von Lena Störfaktor.
Heimlich, still und leise gegen Nazis sein kann jeder. Aber laut gegen Nazis zu sein, dazu gehört Mut. Und genau deshalb präsentiert Fritz.
Laut gegen Nazis.
Das Campus Open Air der BTU-Konfus Senftenberg. Und laut und gegen Nazis auf der Bühne die BeatStates. Und die Leoniden. Open Air auf dem Campus Gelände der BTU-Konfus Senftenberg. Der Eintritt kostet keinen Eintritt. Und kommen kann jeder, der tolerant ist gegenüber Menschen, die anders aussehen, reden, glauben oder lieben.
Siedsänger Demba Nabe ist im Alter von 46 Jahren gestorben. Er war einer der drei Frontmänner der Berliner Band. Nabezai hatte morgen gestorben, teilte der Anwalt von Sied mit. Die Todesursache ist bislang nicht bekannt. Von Nabez Bandkollegen hieß es, die Band trauere um ihren Freund. Erst vor einem Monat hatte Sied eine Tour für den Herbst 2019 angekündigt. In Italien steht nach wochenlangen Verhandlungen eine neue Regierung. Präsident Mattarella erteilte dem parteilosen Juristen Conte den Regierungsauftrag, sagte ein Sprecher. Die Vereidigung soll morgen in Rom stattfinden. Conte wird von der populistischen Fünf-Sterne-Bewegung und der rechten Liga unterstützt. Ein erster Anlauf zur Regierungsbildung war gescheitert, nachdem Mattarella eine Euro-kritischen Kandidaten für einen Ministerposten abgelehnt hatte. Die Bundesregierung hält die von den USA verhängten Zölle auf Stahl- und Aluminium-Importe für rechtswidrig. Regierungsprecher Seibert erklärte, die von den USA angeführten Gründe der nationalen Sicherheit seien nicht ausreichend. EU-Kommissionspräsident Juncker kündigte in Brüssel an, Beschwerde bei der Welthandelsorganisation gegen die US-Zölle einzulegen. Die EU werde außerdem umgehend Gegenmaßnahmen einleiten und ihrerseits Zölle erheben. Die US-Regierung hatte zuvor bekanntgegeben, dass die seit Ende März geltenden Ausnahmeregelungen für die EU nicht verlängert werden. Das Berliner Abgeordnetenhaus hat ein neues Landesdatenschutzgesetz beschlossen. Damit soll die aktuelle EU-Richtlinie zum Datenschutz umgesetzt werden. Berlins Datenschutzbeauftragter kritisierte das Gesetz aber, Berlin würde Auskunftsrechte einschränken und ganze Bereiche, wie z.B. der Rechnungshof, seien von der datenschutzrechtlichen Kontrolle ausgenommen. Durch die neue EU-Verordnung können Bürger besser nachverfolgen, was mit ihren Daten geschieht. Die aktuellen Temperaturen Berlin Mitte 26°, Atlashof 27°, Karlau 21°, Cottbus und Bad Freienwalde 23°, Brandenburg an der Hafe 24°. Leichte Wolken und größtenteils trocken, so wird die Nacht. Nur im Süden und Westen kann es einzelne Schauer und Gewitter geben. Die Tiefstwerte liegen bei 15 bis 20°. Der Tag startet dann mit viel Sonne, im Verlauf bilden sich dann aber auch Quellwolken, die teils kräftige Schauer und Gewitter mitbringen. Dazu wird es sehr warm, mit 30 bis 34°. Und so bleibt es auch in den nächsten Tagen schwül und heiß mit Gewittern zwischendurch. Stadtverkehr Berlin B96, Oranienburger Chaussee zwischen Schwarz-Kittelweg in Frohnau und Berliner Stadtgrenze, Vollsperrung in beiden Richtungen wegen Fahrbahnanäuerung bis morgen früh um 6 und auf der A113 Zubringer Schönefeld statt einwärts, Sperrung zwischen Schönefeld Süd- und Adlershof wegen Wartungsarbeiten. Wo es geht, eine gute Fahrt.
Und weil das hier Chaosradio ist, kommen die Nerd-News gleich hinterher, ebenfalls gelesen von Bene Wenck.
Viele E-Mail-Programme setzen Verschlüsselungsstandards fehlerhaft um. Viele bekannte und beliebte E-Mail-Programme setzen die Verschlüsselungsstandard S-MIME und PGP fehlerhaft um. Forschern von der Fachhochschule Münster tauften das von ihnen gefundene Problem E-Fail. Es handele sich um eine Kombination aus fehlerhafter Umsetzung der Standards und unsicheren Standardeinstellungen. Sicherheitsexperten empfehlen, im E-Mail-Programm auf HTML verzichten, das Nachladen von externen Inhalten deaktivieren und die betroffenen Verschlüsselungsplugins aktualisieren. Die humanistische Union, das Forum InformatikerInnen für Frieden und gesellschaftliche Verantwortung und weitere Organisationen haben den Grundrechte-Report veröffentlicht. Sie wollen damit die Aufmerksamkeit auf die eigentlichen Gefährdungen für den Rechtsstaat und die Grundrechte lenken. Diese gingen nach ihrer Ansicht vom Staat und seinen Institutionen selbst aus. Die offiziellen Verfassungsschutzberichte von Bund und Ländern schilderten lediglich die angeblichen Gefährdungen der freiheitlich-demokratischen Grundordnung. Allerdings hätten sie zu keinem Zeitpunkt die Bundesrepublik ernsthaft in Gefahr bringen können. Der alternative Verfassungsschutzbericht lege dagegen einen Schwerpunkt auf die wahren Einschränkungen von Freiheitsrechten und die überbordende Überwachung. Google hat angekündigt, mit HTTPS überschlüsselter Seiten in seinem Browser Chrome nicht mehr gesondert als gesichert zu markieren. Auch das berühmte Vorhängeschloss hat ausgedient. Stattdessen soll Chrome vor unverschlüsselten Seiten warnen. Benutzer sollten erwarten, dass das Web im Normalfall sicher ist, so die Entwickler. Motillas Browser Firefox beschreitet bereits einen ähnlichen Pfad und warnt, sobald Daten an unverschlüsselt aufgerufene Seiten gesendet werden. In den letzten Jahren ist die Anzahl der unverschlüsselten, übertragenden Seiten im Internet dank Initiativen wie Let's Encrypt stark geschrumpft.
Das waren die Nerd-News mit reingestreuten Stolperstellen hier für Bene Wenk in der Ausgabe Chaosradio 246 um 23 Uhr und jetzt 37 Minuten.
Fritz ist eine Produktion des Rbb.
Und wenn ihr diesen Sound mögt Oder diesen Sound Dann hört doch mal im Club Immer samstags ab 20 Uhr und im Radio. Oder jederzeit auf fritz.de slash Musik Streams. Tschüss!
Chaosradio 246 anwesend, Danimo und nach wie vor Ulf Burmeier. Ihr kennt ihn möglicherweise vom Podcast Lage der Nation. Hier ist er in seiner gesellschaftsrelevanten zweiten Funktion da, nämlich als Gründer und Vorsitzender von der Gesellschaft für Freiheitsrechte. Diese Gesellschaft sucht sich Fälle, mit denen sie unser aller Freiheit sozusagen verteidigen kann, vor allen Dingen vor dem deutschen Gesetzgeber, dass das beispielsweise beim Datenheilereiparagraphen notwendig ist, wie auch beim BND-Gesetz. Das haben wir in den vergangenen Minuten und Stunden schon diskutiert. Jetzt wird es gleich gehen um ein interessantes Gesetz namens Informationsfreiheitsgesetz, das es in Deutschland so ungefähr, glaube ich, seit 2005 gibt, das allerdings noch Wünsche offen lässt. Aber man kann darüber schon viele Informationen einholen. Manche werden allerdings dann nicht gewährt. Und das sind dann Fälle, die wieder bei der GFF landen, wo sie sich darum kümmert, dass Auskünfte aus deutschen Behörden dann eben doch erteilt werden. Ulf, das Informationsfreiheitsgesetz, du bist Fan, ne?
Ich bin grundsätzlich ein Fan des IFG. Ich finde, es könnte ein paar weniger Ausnahmen enthalten. Was sind denn da so Ausnahmen? Es gibt relativ weitgehende Möglichkeiten, bestimmte Informationen aus Behördenakten doch nicht rauszugeben. Ein Klassiker sind zum Beispiel Geschäftsgeheimnisse. Wenn Firmen sich beispielsweise bei einer Ausschreibung bewerben, dann kann man grundsätzlich nicht mit einer IFG-Anfrage mal so herausfinden, was zum Beispiel die Mitbewerber so angeboten haben. Das macht während der Laufenden Ausschreibung Sinn. Aber ehrlich gesagt, ein, zwei Jahre später wäre es doch schon mal interessant zu sehen, wie denn da eigentlich der Markt so aussah. Da kann man ja auch nicht mehr wirklich von Geschäftsgeheimnissen reden. Trotzdem müssen dann immer noch die Firmen gefragt werden, ob sie einverstanden sind. Normalerweise sind sie natürlich nicht einverstanden. Diese Dinge offen zu legen. Das ist so ein Klassiker. Und natürlich gibt es auch Ausnahmen, z.B. in manchen Bundesländern, die ausgesprochen problematisch sind. Das ist ein Fall, wo wir sagen müssen, da hat die GFF vor Gericht mal verloren.
Alle denken hier so, Bayern.
Aber in diesem Fall ist es das beschauliche Rheinland-Pfalz, das nämlich seit einiger Zeit ein neues sogenanntes Transparenzgesetz hat. Das aber in einem interessanten Punkt eher ein Intransparenzgesetz ist. Nämlich, da ist der gesamte Bereich der Drittmittelforschung an Universitäten ausgeklammert aus der Informationsfreiheit. Ich kann also eine Universität nicht fragen, welches Industrieunternehmen zum Beispiel einem Professor Millionen dafür zahlt, dass er, keine Ahnung, irgendwelche Mitarbeiter einstellen kann. Und deswegen kann man dann eben nicht so richtig prüfen, welche inhaltlichen Vorgaben dieses Unternehmen möglicherweise gemacht hat für Forschung und Lehre. Und das zum Beispiel finde ich ausgesprochen bedenklich. Ich finde es ja wunderbar, wenn quasi Wissenschaft und Praxis zusammenfinden. Aber ich wüsste schon gerne, auf welche Art und Weise die Industrie dann mit ihrem Geld Einfluss darauf nimmt, was die theoretisch freie Wissenschaft so tut.
Interessante Auslassungen bei diesem Gesetz. Tatsächlich muss ich ausdustimmen.
Es gibt eine Sparre.
Richtig. Was sind denn die Menschen, die zu euch kommen, deren Begehren abgeschmettert wurde beispielsweise? Ihr habt ja einige Transparenzklagen, glaube ich.
Ja, wir haben quasi ein Programm Transparenzklagen. Häufig, nicht immer, häufig in Zusammenarbeit mit Frag den Staat. Ja, Frag den Staat ist ja eine Internetplattform, wo man relativ einfach Informationsfreiheitsgesetzanfragen stellen kann an Behörden. Diese Plattform stellt einem so Fragen, das heißt, sie ermöglicht es einem da besonders gut, besonders einfach, richtige Anfragen zu stellen.
Was ja auch ein bisschen kompliziert ist dann wahrscheinlich.
Ja, es gibt da halt so eine Reihe von Textbausteinen, die man am besten reinbauen sollte und die gibt einem Frag den Staat einfach sehr gut vor. Das ist jetzt keine Raketenwissenschaft, aber es macht schon Sinn, das über Frag den Staat zu machen, denn dann macht man einfach bestimmte Fehler nicht. Und wenn man da aber keinen Erfolg hat, wenn also diese Anfrage abgelehnt wird, dann kann man sich bei uns bewerben um eine sogenannte Transparenzpatenschaft. Und wenn wir sagen, dieser Fall ist ein Fall für die GFF, dann bezahlen wir quasi die Gerichtskosten vor dem Verwaltungsgericht erst mal in der ersten Instanz und auch die Anwaltskosten. Das heißt also dann kann man als Bürgerin oder als Bürger kostenfrei die Behörde versuchen zu zwingen, dass sie diese Informationen eben doch herausgibt.
Was sind denn das für Informationen, die da gewünscht werden von Bürgern? Das ist ja offenbar angenommen worden, es werden Anfragen gestellt.
Ja, eine ganze Reihe. Es ist ein ganz ganz buntes Feld. Wir haben zum Beispiel eine Anfrage, da geht es um Protokolle der Bundesregierung und zwar aus den entscheidenden Sitzungen, als das Leistungsschutzrecht für Presseverlage beschlossen wurde. Hier will ich jetzt gar nichts detailgen, aber jedenfalls ein sehr umstrittenes Gesetz, das maßgeblich gefordert wurde von Lobbyisten aus dem Springer Verlag. Und damals war es so, dass einer von zwei Brüdern beim Springer Verlag beschäftigt war und der andere in hoher Funktion in der Bundesregierung. Und da wollte einfach ein Journalist gerne wissen, ob denn zufälligerweise bei der entscheidenden Sitzung dieser Bruder, des Springer Lobbyisten, auch dabei war. Das wäre eine interessante Frage gewesen. Und das will die Bundesregierung eben nicht rausrücken. Dieses Protokoll bekommt er nicht und das ist einer der Fälle. Natürlich kann man jetzt sagen, das ist vielleicht nicht der, wie soll ich sagen, das ist keine ganz zentrale Frage für den Bestand unseres Staates, aber es stellen sich einfach sehr interessante Rechtsfragen, gerade so aus der Perspektive, was darf man denn so alles ablehnen? Es gibt ja sowas wie einen geschützten Kernbereich der exekutiven Meinungsbildung, wo die Bundesregierung sich quasi nicht in die Karten gucken lassen muss und in dem Verfahren geht es unter anderem darum, wie weit reicht quasi so dieser Geheimbereich, wo die Bundesregierung sich im Geheimen eine Meinung bilden kann.
Behandelt ihr eigentlich auch Fälle, wo Behörden exorbitante Gebühren für Auskünfte verlangt haben oder lässt sich das meistens anders regeln?
Das war kein Fall, den wir durchgeklagt haben, sondern ich glaube, der war von Korrektiv. Ich bin völlig täuscht, es ist so, dass es einen bestimmten Gebührendeckel gibt bei der Bearbeitung von solchen Anfragen nach dem Informationsfreiheitsgesetz. Wenn man aber natürlich eine Frage quasi willkürlich stückelt als Behörde und sagt, also diese eine Anfrage betrifft aber 500 Aktenordner und dann erhebt man die Gebühr für jeden Aktenordner einzeln, die Höchstgebühr, dann kann es mit einmal sehr, sehr teuer werden und deswegen hatte ich meinen, es war Korrektiv. Bin ich ganz sicher hat Korrektiv, glaube ich, mal geklagt und haben dann auch gewonnen. Das war also kein Fall der GFF. Jedenfalls ist jetzt klar, man darf als Behörde eine einzelne Anfrage nicht willkürlich stuckeln, sondern eine Anfrage ist tatsächlich im Prinzip auch eine Anfrage.
Jetzt haben wir auch eine Anfrage und zwar von Josef. Hallo Josef. Du hast eine sehr expertige Frage und zwar fragst du hier zumindest, ist das das, was beim Redakteur angekommen ist und bei mir, was denn Ulf, nehme ich mal an vor allen Dingen vom schwedischen Informationsfreiheitsgesetz handelt. Jetzt haben wir hier intern schon gesprochen, Ulf kennt das schwedische Freiheitsinformationsgesetz nicht, Informationsfreiheitsgesetz. Aber vielleicht können wir dich fragen, Josef, welchen Punkt du da meinst? Ja, Schweden ist ja quasi die Mutter aller Freiheitsgesetze. Das nennt sich da Öffentlichkeitsprinzip. Das ist das Recht bei Behörden und Ämtern in alle Akten und Dokumente Einsicht nehmen zu können. Das bedeutet, dass alle in einer Behörde vorhandenen Akten und Dokumente einschließlich Bandaufnahmen und computergespeicherte Daten für die Allgemeinheit zugänglich sind. Und dieses Recht besteht schon in Schweden seit 1766.
Die USA zum Beispiel haben ihren Freedom of Information Act erst 1966 beschlossen.
200 Jahre später, und wir haben dann nochmal 50 Jahre in Deutschland abgewartet, dass unser Informationsfreiheitsgesetz im Vergleich zu Schweden sehr intransparent ist. Weil zum Beispiel in Schweden gehen sie ja so weit, dass auch alle Steuererklärungen offen, öffentlich sind.
Genau, da wollte ich gerade hin. Um Korruption zu verhindern zum Beispiel.
Ja, also das heißt, es geht noch immer besser. Wo siehst du denn Ulf, die Verbesserungen beim Informationsfreiheitsgesetz? Also wenn du das jetzt so hörst, Schweden, das muss man wahrscheinlich einschränken. Die werden auch irgendwelche Staatsgeheimnisse haben, nachdem man dann eben nicht fragen kann. Tippe ich mal, keine Ahnung. Aber wo würdest du den ansetzen beim deutschen Informationsfreiheitsgesetz, um zu sagen, da muss man ran?
Also ich habe ja eben schon den Punkt genannt, Geschäftsgeheimnisse. Das ist eben sehr häufig ein Trick, wie Behörden eben doch viele Informationen dann nicht rausrücken. Das ist auch zum Beispiel ein Thema jetzt bei dem besonderen elektronischen Anwaltspostfach. Das ist ja so eine der aktuellen Skandale, die jemand aus dem CCC aufgedeckt hat. Massive Sicherheitslücken bei dem bald obligatorischen Mittel der Anwaltskommunikation in Deutschland. Auch da ist es so, dass wesentliche Informationen eben nicht an die Öffentlichkeit kommen, weil die beteiligten Firmen sagen, nein, das sind unsere Geschäftsgeheimnisse. Und da muss man denke ich sagen, bislang haben da solche Geschäftsgeheimnisse eine extrem starke Stellung. Und ich denke, das wird eine der politischen Aufgaben der nächsten Jahre sein, die einfach mindestens sowas wie eine Abwägung einzuführen, dass also Geschäftsgeheimnisse nicht quasi wie ein Trumpf alle anderen Argumente stechen, sondern dass sie nur abgewogen werden müssen mit zum Beispiel dem Interesse der Öffentlichkeit. Und ein weiterer wichtiger Punkt wäre aus meiner Sicht so eine Art Sunset-Klausel, dass Geschäftsgeheimnisse eben nicht bis in alle Ewigkeit Geschäftsgeheimnisse bleiben, sondern dass man sagt, okay, die mögen heute geschützt sein, aber ich hatte das Beispiel mit den Ausschreibungen ja eben schon gebracht. Jedenfalls nach einigen Jahren ist die Kalkulation in einer Ausschreibung oder bei einer Bewerbung für eine Ausschreibung einfach nicht mehr schutzwürdig. Dass man halt sagt, Geschäftsgeheimnis ist jedenfalls nach drei Jahren oder nach fünf Jahren je nach den Umständen nicht mehr schutzwürdig. Das sind so Themen, an denen man, denke ich, arbeiten kann. Dann gibt es natürlich ganze Bereichsausnahmen für Behörden wie den Bundesnachrichtendienst oder manche Rechnungshöfe, die völlig ausgeklammert sind. Da kann man sich auch die Frage stellen, wie viel Sinn macht das? Da hat jemand mal, vielleicht auch so halbscherzhaft, nach dem Speiseplan der Kantine des BND gefragt. Und auch da wurde gesagt, nö, BND gibt es nicht. Wo man sich schon fragen kann, warum ist dieser Speiseplan top secret?
Hältst du so was für machbar, so ein umfassendes Gesetz, wie das offenbar in Schweden zu sein scheint?
Also ich denke, dass es einfach wirklich ein Kulturwandel ist, den wir so langsam aber sicher sehen in den Behörden, der aber eben noch nicht abgeschlossen ist. Und es gibt eben auch eine Gegenbewegung. Es gibt eben inzwischen auch schon den Effekt, dass viele Informationen einfach gar nicht mehr zu den Akten gegeben werden, sondern zum Beispiel per E-Mail ausgetauscht, nicht ausgedruckt werden oder nur in irgendwelchen schwarzen Akten parallel geführt werden, die dann gar nicht zum Bestandteil der offiziellen Akten werden. Das kann man manchmal sogar nachweisen, wenn man also Unterlagen bekommt bei einer IFG-Anfrage, wo Bezug genommen wird auf andere Unterlagen, die offensichtlich nicht Bestandteil der Akte geworden sind. Das ist, muss man sagen, eine deutliche Umgehung der Informationsfreiheit, wenn Behörden parallel Akten führen oder schwarze Akten führen, die dann eben nicht rausgegeben werden. Ich hoffe, dass das nicht der Standardfall ist, aber das sieht man. Und deswegen spreche ich von einem Kulturwandel. Das wird man nicht nur mit Gesetzen erreichen können, sondern das ist auch einfach eine Frage der Überzeugungsarbeit in den Behörden. Da muss man die Mitarbeiterinnen und Mitarbeiter mitnehmen und ihnen einfach sagen, das ist gut, wenn die Menschen hier sehen, was ihr tut. Das ist gut, denn zum einen haben sie es bezahlt, ganz banal. Öffentliche Gelder sollten auch zu öffentlichen Daten führen. Das ist das eine. Und zum anderen dient es aber natürlich auch der Vertrauensbildung. Wenn ich also schauen kann, was eigentlich eine Behörde so tut, dann habe ich unter Umständen ein viel größeres Vertrauen darin, dass die Behörde nach Recht und Gesetz arbeitet. Und davon gehe ich einfach aus, dass das das Ziel aller Mitarbeiterinnen und Mitarbeiter ist, dass sie sich selbstverständlich versuchen, an das Recht zu halten.
Ich habe noch eine kurze Anmerkung, darf ich? Ja, natürlich.
Zum Thema Post, das ist doch auch eine Sache, die eigentlich auch komplett unsicher ist.
In den USA werden schon seit etlichen Jahren der komplette Briefverkehr gespeichert. Das heißt, wer, wem, wo und wie Post schickt. Es ist in den USA offiziell bekannt, dass die Post jeden Brief einscannt und speichert, wer wie kommuniziert hat, um eventuelle Terroranschläge zu verhindern. Auch die deutsche Post speichert Adressen angeblich nur für drei Tage.
Ob das stimmt, weiß man nicht.
Mit den drei Tagen, da fies einscannt, wurde schon offiziell zugegeben. Und dann noch eine andere Anmerkung.
Früher in der DDR wurden die Briefe mit Heißdampf und so aufgemacht.
Das braucht man ja heute auch nicht mehr machen. Es gibt Techniken mit Terrorherzstrahlung, wo ich geschlossene Bücher lesen kann. Über mehrere Seiten dicke.
Also 30 Seiten sind mir aktuell bekannt, dass die Technik so weit ist. Dass ich ein komplett geschlossenes Buch lesen kann.
Und das ist jetzt erst dann schon zwei Jahre alt.
Das heißt, es wird wahrscheinlich schon mehr möglich sein, an geschlossene Informationen in Büchern oder Unterlagen zu kommen, ohne sie äußerlich nur anfassen zu müssen.
Also das heißt, wenn wir vorhin davon gesprochen haben, Dokumente schriftlich einzureichen, ist es möglicherweise auch nicht unbedingt sinnvoll. Josef, ich verstehe das mal so als Eingabe. Wir wollten gleich noch ein bisschen über das Polizeiaufgabengesetz sprechen. Wir haben nur noch zehn Minuten. Am Ende drückt der Schuh natürlich immer. Ich danke dir vielmals für den Anruf, Josef. Bis dann, tschau. Ja, hier war so ein stilles Knop. Kopfnicken bei der Terra-Strahlung. Danimo, schon mal untergekommen, sowas?
Ja, Terraherzscanner sind ja auch das, was man mittlerweile an den Flughäfen hat.
Mit Armen hoch, wo die Schweißflecken immer rauskommen.
Genau, das ist im Prinzip, das dürfte im Prinzip das gleiche Verfahren sein. Auch da geht es bis knapp unter die Haut, wenn er jetzt sagt 30 Seiten. Ich stecke in dem Thema jetzt selber auch nicht genau drin, aber es wäre zumindest vorstellbar, dass generell Metadaten, also auch im Brief verkehren, irgendwie eine Form gespeichert werden. Die Maschinen können das, das weiß ich. Inwieweit es da gesetzliche Grundlagen für gibt, bin ich mir jetzt nicht sicher.
Also nicht besorgniserregend, Ulf?
Ja, das ist in der Tat keine Neuigkeit, dass Briefe abfotografiert werden, dass quasi die Empfänger- und die Absenderanschriften gespeichert werden. Ich weiß nicht ganz genau, wer das konkret macht und auf welcher Grundlage, aber ich weiß, dass das tatsächlich schon passiert. Deswegen, wenn man eben Dinge an einen Journalisten schickt, sollte man natürlich keinen Absender draufschreiben. Das versteht sich von selber. Oder wenn überhaupt, sollte man das in den Brief schreiben, wenn man sehr mutig ist.
Okay, wir reden noch ganz kurz. Die wenigen verbleibenden Minuten über das Polizeiaufgabengesetz hat immerhin geschafft, obwohl es auch nicht weniger kompliziert ist, als die Dinge, über die wir uns jetzt hier gerade unterhalten haben, 30.000 Menschen auf die Straße zu bringen. Die alle aufgebracht waren in München, weil möglicherweise so Dinge möglich sind wie Polizisten, die Handgranaten tragen. Und was war noch drin? Dass man das Durchsuchen und Verändern von Daten, beispielsweise der Polizei, erlaubte. Und vor allen Dingen, dass man sozusagen den Einsatzmoment der Polizei herabverringert auf eine drohende Gefahr. Das heißt, sie muss nicht mehr abwarten, bis eine konkrete Gefahr vorliegt, sondern sie kann schon vorgehen und ermitteln und möglicherweise ausspionieren, wenn nur eine Gefahr droht. Und das klingt sehr schwammig. Die Handgranaten, Ulf, habe ich gelesen, sind eine Legende.
Die Handgranaten sollen nämlich schon vorher zulässig gewesen sein. So viel zum Thema Bayern. Ich meine mal ganz ehrlich, alle Kriminalstatistiken weisen ja aus, dass Deutschland insgesamt, nicht nur der Freistaat Bayern, Jahr für Jahr sicherer wird. Wir haben immer weniger, jedenfalls der Polizei, bekannt gewordene Straftaten. Insofern kann man sich schon mal ganz generell die Frage stellen, warum eigentlich muss ein Polizeigesetz massiv nachgeschärft werden, wenn doch ganz offensichtlich die Lage eigentlich gar nicht so wahnsinnig problematisch ist.
Erneuert werden müssen sie immer. Das war jetzt dem vorausgegangen das BKA-Gesetz oder so. Und deswegen müssen sie angepasst werden, oder um neue Datenschutzverordnungen damit einzupassen. Deswegen musste das novelliert werden. Und in dem Zuge, so wie ich es verstanden habe, hat Bayern gesagt, dann schreiben wir noch ein paar andere Sachen mit rein.
Da hätte man halt, wenn man es gewollt hätte, auch einfach nur quasi die Datenschutzregeln und ein paar Informationsregeln ändern können. Nein, man hat dann eben auf breiter Front die Möglichkeiten der Polizei erweitert. Und diese Einzelmaßnahmen finde ich persönlich gar nicht das wirklich Problematische an dem Gesetz, sondern das Problematische ist aus meiner Sicht und auch aus Sicht der Gesellschaft für Freiheitsrechte dieses Schlagwort der drohenden Gefahr. Dazu muss man wissen, dass die Polizei ja zuständig ist für die Gefahrenabwehr. Also jedenfalls, wenn wir jetzt vom Polizeiaufgabengesetz sprechen, geht es nicht um die Bekämpfung von Straftaten. Das geht nach anderen Gesetzen, vor allem nach der Strafprozessordnung, sondern hier sind wir nur im Bereich des sogenannten präventiven Handelns, also wo die Polizei versucht zu verhindern, dass irgendwas schiefgeht. Dass also ein Schaden eintritt für ein Rechtsgut, dass jemand verletzt wird, das Eigentum beschädigt wird, dass schlimmstenfalls jemand stirbt. Das Prävention, Verhinderung des Eintritts von Schäden ist der Gegenstand des Polizeiaufgabengesetzes. Und da war es bislang eben so, dass die Polizei nur in Bürgerrechte eingreifen durfte, in Fällen einer konkreten Gefahr. Das heißt also, wenn unmittelbar eine Situation bestand, wenn man also quasi Tatsachen festnageln konnte, bei denen zu befürchten war, dass jetzt bald, wenn es so weitergeht, wenn sich eine Situation weiterentwickelt, ein Schaden eintritt. Und diese Voraussetzung, die war natürlich relativ eng. Das konnte man immer noch annehmen. Die Polizei hat natürlich immer schon einen Einschätzungsspielraum gehabt. Reicht uns das jetzt an Gefahr, ja oder nein? Aber das war jedenfalls etwas, was man notfalls auch noch gerichtlich kontrollieren konnte. Und bei der drohenden Gefahr wird das jetzt weitaus abstrakter gefasst. Das heißt also, die Polizei bekommt einen wesentlich größeren Spielraum bei der Einschätzung. Denn es muss eben keine konkrete Gefahr mehr sein, sondern es muss nur drohen. Es muss eine Situation sein, die dazu führen könnte, dass es irgendwann wahrscheinlich wird, dass ein Schaden eintritt. Also quasi ein Level an Indirection mehr. Eine Ebene von Präzision weniger. Und das bedeutet in der Praxis, dass man einfach nicht mehr gerichtlich prüfen kann, ob die Polizei richtig gehandelt hat oder nicht. Das ist das eigentliche Problem dabei. Also zum einen wird die Polizei nicht mehr angehalten, wirklich zu prüfen, brennt hier gleich was an, ja oder nein, sondern sie kann weit im Vorfeld tätig werden. Und zum zweiten kann man hinterher auch, also man kann natürlich immer noch hingehen zum Gericht, aber das Gericht hat kaum jemals die Möglichkeit festzustellen, hier lag eine Situation vor, in der völlig ausgeschlossen war, dass es mal richtig brenzlig werden könnte.
Deswegen ist es von deiner Warte aus schon gerechtfertigt, dass da so viele Leute auf dem Platz standen und dagegen demonstriert haben, nehme ich mal an. Es wird jetzt aber so umgesetzt, wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe, oder ist schon so weit, oder lässt sich dann noch was machen?
Also das Gesetz ist jedenfalls vom Landtag in Bayern beschlossen und es ist auch in Kraft getreten, soweit ich weiß. Ich meine, vor ein paar Jahren ist auch in Kraft getreten, jedenfalls verkündet ist es schon im Gesetzblatt für den Freistaat Bayern. Aber das ist natürlich nicht das letzte Wort, die Gesellschaft für Freiheitsrechte hat ein Crowdfunding gemacht, um eine Klage zu finanzieren, eine Verfassungsbeschwerde von dem Bundesverfassungsgericht gegen dieses neue Bayerische Polizeiaufgabengesetz. Und dabei wird der Begriff der drohenden Gefahr eine ganz zentrale Rolle spielen. Das Crowdfunding war auch relativ erfolgreich. Wir haben nicht ganz die Fundingschwelle erreicht, sind aber sehr zuversichtlich, dass das gelingen kann. Und wir versuchen da zur Zeit eine Zusammenarbeit zu organisieren mit dem Bayerischen NoPak-Bündnis. Das ist also ein Bündnis von inzwischen über 90 Organisationen aus der Zivilgesellschaft. Auch die meisten Parteien sind da mit dabei, außer der CSU natürlich. Und wir wollen versuchen, mit diesem breiten gesellschaftlichen Bündnis gemeinsam und vermutlich auch mit einem Anwalt aus München zusammen gegen dieses Gesetz nach Karlsruhe zu ziehen.
Und damit sind wir auch am entscheidenden Punkt hier kurz vor Ende dieser Sendung. Die GFF finanziert sich natürlich über Spenden und das möglicherweise auch über eure. Ihr habt einen Spendenbutton auf der Seite freiheitsrechte.org, wenn euch die Arbeit der GFF gefällt und ihr sie wichtig findet, dann könnt ihr dorthin gehen. Wie finanziert ihr euch ansonsten nur über diese Spenden oder diese Crowdfunding-Deals, die ihr da macht für konkrete Geschichten? Oder gibt es auch sozusagen so Big Donors, die im Hintergrund stehen und sagen, ich gebe Geld dafür, dass das ordentlich läuft?
Also wir finanzieren uns am allerliebsten über kleine Spenden und über Fördermitgliedschaften. Das ist unser allerliebstes. Also Menschen, die sagen, ich unterstütze die GFF jedes Jahr mit einem bestimmten Beitrag. Das ist das Allerschönste, weil es uns einfach eine gewisse Planungssicherheit ermöglicht, dass man also auch Menschen einstellen kann. Wir wollen ja jetzt nicht hire and fire mäßig Leute einstellen und nach einem Jahr sie wieder rausschmeißen, weil das Geld alle ist. Deswegen sind die Fördermitgliedschaften besonders klasse. Ansonsten haben wir inzwischen viele tausend Menschen, die mit kleinen und größeren Spenden die Arbeit der GFF ermöglichen. Dafür sind wir sehr, sehr dankbar. Wir haben aber auch einige wenige größere Spende, aber der Anteil der Einzelspenden und der Fördermitgliedschaften liegt bei deutlich über 50 Prozent. Ich glaube, es sind so zwischen 60 und 70 Prozent, die von kleineren Geldgebern stammen. Und das finden wir sehr, sehr schön, weil wir dann einfach nicht von einzelnen Zuwendungen abhängig sind, sondern dann kann also tatsächlich die GFF eigenverantwortlich ihre Prioritäten festlegen. Und wir müssen jetzt nicht darauf Rücksicht nehmen, dass irgendein großer Spender sagt, klagt doch mal hier gegen oder viel schlimmer noch, klagt mal nicht dagegen.
Wir haben über Freiheitsrechte gesprochen hier im Chaosradio 246, wo ich ausnahmsweise eingesprungen bin für den lieben Kollegen Markus Richter, der verhindert war. Danimo sieht es mir noch gegenüber. Am Ende, Danimo, dann sagt ihr doch bestimmt noch irgendwelche Links durch oder man kann hier noch was hören oder klicken oder sowas, dass ich alles immer nicht weiß.
Achso, nee, jetzt erstmal nichts Konkretes. Auf jeden Fall könnt ihr diese Sendung nachhören unter Chaosradio CCCDE in den nächsten Tagen. Das Video wird es dann auch auf MediaCCCDE geben. Und ich kann euch auch nur noch mal empfehlen, Fördermitglied, GFF habe ich gemacht, finde ich wichtig, macht das auch.
Fühlt sich gut an. Ich bedanke mich beim Chaosradio, dass sie mich hier ausgehalten haben. Es hat geruckelt und gewackelt ein wenig. Ich bitte, das zu entschuldigen, auch beim Podcast. Es wird nicht rausgeschnitten, sondern bleibt für alle Ewigkeit erhalten. Ich bedanke mich bei Ulf Burmeier, der hier für uns da war und zwei Stunden Expertise gegeben hat über die GFF und vor allen Dingen natürlich auch über Freiheitsrechte und wie man sie verteidigt und natürlich auch der Kollege Nora Markath, die uns über Skype zugeschaltet war, ebenfalls von der GFF. Vielen Dank und machts gut. Bis dann, tschüss.